it's very visual everything we do
you see on the screen and and it has
that thing that people that are coming
to work in browser
not necessarily leaving so quickly
because because it it is really
inspiring just to open the computer in
the morning and have that 3d you know
rotating and that makes your day already
and from from the very beginning of the
day
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opus labs synergy global hello
at stanford leap birthright excel serona
partners and in media partnership with
c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders meet
avechai feld the ceo at browseware
avechai has been pioneering the
development of digital technologies that
enable the fashion industry to thrive in
the increasingly virtual world since the
late 90s as co-founder and ceo of
browseware he leads the company's
strategy and vision while also
spearheading the creation and delivery
of solutions that are making the apparel
businesses more efficient and
sustainable both economically and
ecologically
in addition to his experience working
with fashion designer manufacturing
avihai previously led startups with
technologies for e-commerce and gaming
he is a graduate of tel aviv university
where he studied physics computer
science and mathematics
avi haifeld welcome to 20 minute leaders
i'm so excited to have you here how are
you i'm very good thank you
happy to be here
speaking to an entrepreneur i i get so
much energy from it and and especially
when it's about something that people
don't really stop to think about and
it's such a an interesting place that
you're in with browse where and your
previous companies that you've been
involved with as an entrepreneur as a
cpo as a general manager so many
interesting things about your career of
ichai and and today with browse we're
looking at the the product the
productionization
and the creation of apparel with some of
the biggest brands in the world more
than 650 brands over 150 employees and i
i can't wait to hear the story behind it
before we get there who who who is this
person in front of me right now
just your regular uh um high-tech person
from uh from israel
um
you know i've studied computer science
and mathematics uh years and years and
years back
and all i did back in the university was
fantasizing on 3d worlds and you know
how would how would that look like way
before it was really uh you know
existing for real but but yes
i'm talking about
1995 we've been discussing virtual
reality
whereas today you know finally finally
in the in the 2020 2019 suddenly people
started talking about their vr but back
at the time
it was kind of you know really
far-fetched but that's what that's what
moved me back then and that's what's
still moving me today
apparel any connection with apparel for
you oh
first of all i always liked
buying clothes but really he was the guy
you're the one guy that enjoys buying
clothes i found it
yeah
i'm sure that there are many like me but
really the connection the connection
happened when one day i it was
i remember it clearly i was
in the middle of of developing our own
3d engine and looking into 3d
environments and and
you know spending huge amount of time in
going around
3d
spaces and and the one thing we thought
is how do you make money out of this how
do you really turn it into something
that people want to use
and then it suddenly hit me you know the
one place that 3d in real time by the
way would be useful is
how would you then look at yourself uh
um you know on the web trying clothes
without 3d if you really want to you
want to know how you look like you need
the whole 3d right the whole 360
and then that would be the very basics
of anything that will connect you
to how does garment fit you and back at
the time we're talking now on on
wow
internet was at the beginning of it and
you know
it was about the same if you look at the
experience of shopping for apparel back
then and today hey it's not so different
it's still the same catalogs with images
and you still don't get to see yourself
dressed in any of the styles even today
2021 but back at the time it seemed so
logical for me that if
if i want to see if i want to buy a
style okay a garment over the net
i just need to have that same experience
as i have in real life in physical life
which you know i can dress on and i can
try on and i can look at the mirror and
i can look back and forth except on the
computer and it sounded so
easy and straightforward and you know
that's where the journey started
so that the journey is starting in 99
right 1999 absolutely
is it
you know i was i was three years old
back then and i i wasn't purchasing i
wasn't purchasing clothes but
you know the people
think the way you did you know you're
looking at the way consumers are going
to need to digitally you know
feel how the product they're going to
purchase is going to react in the real
world was this you know if you were to
talk to people about this in this middle
of the street would everybody just agree
with you intuitively
well
interesting question because you know on
one hand
many of them
specifically from the industry itself
once we started moving inside the um
and the different brands trying to
explain the the idea
it was hard for them to imagine how good
can it become
when they are dealing with the actual
physical thing otherwise i mean the
other people who were already
purchasing from the web trying that for
them it it was it it meant more because
for them buying then and buying today's
is the same it's
it's buying you know using your
imagination mostly and not being able to
understand what is it that you're buying
how is it going to fit yourself so that
was kind of an easy
the easy part of explaining to people
who are your usual buyers
the industry was really tough i mean
this traditional industry
which cares about every thread that goes
through their creation
then
they were the hardest uh part of of
getting people to understand from the
industry that this can actually be done
on the computer that i mean by being
able to represent styles over your own
body and being able to then make a
decision as a shopper whether i like it
or not on the web that was a hard
mission back then
so direct to consumer today different
you know you decided to change to a
different part of the life cycle of you
know the clothing creation from the from
the thought process of the designer all
the way to when it reaches you know the
customer's home via e-commerce
traditionally today
why why the change
oh that that change happened way before
i'm talking about back in 2001 when the
first bubble exploded right in front of
our face
and then for a couple of years there
wasn't i mean direct to consumer
was less of an interest of investors and
money was was not going into this but
that being said
what we really
understood is that with the technology
that we've already developed there's a
way
to see garments you know in the way that
they're going to look like way before
you're actually manufacturing them and
that was an asset
and anyway it kind of chimed
pretty well with the idea that one day
if we come back to direct to consumer
you need those 3d assets
as as part of what's going to meet the
consumer but back at the time we're
talking 2001
the immediate idea was you know the
option for me as as a manager was to
either close the company or
to pivot it into something else and
pivoting was not less interesting being
able to take this
3d asset and help now the pre-production
of the um
of the entire garment in the industry to
make decision over
3d digital styles
that was suddenly realized as super
interesting that could shorten i mean
back at the time we talked about two
years
you know of of average process today by
the way without us it's still 50 weeks
average
of you know since the get-go to your
styles on the shelves being ready to
what is the get go as a get go the when
you know a graphic designer sits down
and has this vision for how a cl a piece
of clothing with the look and feel
almost i mean when you're talking about
big enterprises and this is our major
clients you know going all the way from
the biggest retail in the world like
walmart columbia adidas yeah and then
the brands which are the uh you know the
the nikes of the world the the
lululemons the the ralph lauren and so
on
these guys have calendars and they have
their own cadence and for them to be
able to be ready for this uh winter they
have started anywhere between a year or
a year and a half ahead of time
depending on which you know garments are
we speaking when it comes to uh um and
it starts with a brief okay so when it
comes to a down jacket it takes at least
a year and a half to to to you know from
brief
to jacket is ready wow and only that i
mean really using the the previous
methods not only that i mean if you look
today from sustainability perspective
it's impossible because the way it's
done i mean once it became all
globalized is that the factories which
are then usually in china or anywhere in
asia and mostly
those will be getting the brief or they
will be getting a sketch from the
designer that sits in in the western
country
the the chinese guys it usually doesn't
even speak the language will need to
then translate do something that will
take them couple of weeks then we'll
need to send it it will need to fly you
know that immediately has a
carbon footprint which is today you know
it's impossible to think about it
because it goes once to the west you
know what are the chances that the
designer who did that would really like
what they what they see
they would then mark what's wrong on the
government they will write their
notifications send it back again another
flight going to china hey this and this
goes back and forth and there you go you
know anywhere between a year and a half
of course t-shirt will take a bit less
but we are here
50 weeks of average time impossible
then we come in when we come in with a
3d
visualization it's not us it's our
clients using our tools and our solution
to create the samples which are the
necessities it's the necessary evil for
this industry to make decisions but
instead when they make it with our
solution
it takes you know we narrow the time in
not only we narrow the time for the
first initial sample
once you know that person in the west is
getting the 3d sample they're looking at
it they can immediately respond on it
they can write the feedback and they can
see it first of all they can see it okay
they can see it in 3d they look at it as
if it was the real garment they can
rotate it look it from all sides up and
down send their
feedback and tomorrow you know usually
because it's different time zones
tomorrow they will get the whole thing
fixed
now they can make 100 changes to it and
they will still end up in one week and
there you go
so bottom line we do change the the face
of this uh industry it changes
completely and then not only this
think about the sustainability it should
be instead of the brands taking a
decision
now on we need a million pieces of this
and then taking out to the market trying
to sell it instead what we are offering
them today
is to sell first
then produce
now being able to take that through to
life 3d sample putting it in front of
your consumer
understand what do they want and only
then
going into manufacturing that's even a
bigger change to this industry it
doesn't really happen yet on a vast you
know
on a mess if you want but
i think this is part of the vision that
will actually change everything they the
the brands will start creating something
that people really want to buy instead
of throwing 50 of it so that's what
we're about in browser today
but that being said
that being said now there's a big
opportunity for us to go back
into consumers as well because this is a
a this is
one of those missing links that you know
i personally have the the
the passion to go back into that and i
think that the people that are following
me
uh within the company and outside this
company they are also big believers in
that i mean being able to take this
asset that was used for all the decision
making in the pre-production
and then do whatever tweaks are required
and putting it in front of you as a
consumer letting you
understand how it will look on you what
is the real size what fits you what is
the size that you would like to buy
and make that decision
online
that's huge
that's huge from from you know from
several aspects number one because
people people will start buying things
that today they they don't really buy
online because they think that they
would need to actually try it on and see
how it looks like so i'm we're hoping
that that will change the things number
two
there is that thing today which is the
the whole
return policy which allows you to take
you know
to order three four or five and whatever
number of sizes you want in colors and
then just return those that you don't
want
i mean that policy is is also i mean
it's clearly understood from uh
from the brand's perspective but
it also has its contribution to waste
because once those elements are being
returned into the uh into the brand
they're not necessarily uh
can be put into sales again you know
they might come back
you know later from from the actual
season
and the brand will accept them but then
they will throw them away so that is
also a big contributor to waste
but if we can help the consumers to
understand exactly what they want to
shop for they won't be needing to
order you know huge amount of
options and then return you know 90 of
it so so that again is one of the of the
things that we might be able to solve
going directly to consumers
incredible abihai take me back to your
childhood
10 years old
what fascinates you
i'm so old i can't remember yes
what what made you really curious on a
truly honest way what led your curiosity
in your day today
uh yeah there was some some
uh um
sci-fi i was always
science fiction for me was always that
thing that you know i could not have
enough room
wow very very cool
and
today by the way any specific show any
specific book
a book series that you were especially
into all of them
one of them you know
there will be you know television series
that i were there before you were born
now that i know your age
okay it was alpha 1999 for them that was
the future
and then there was of course star trek
and all those i mean yeah i heard there
was something called star trek and star
wars back then
to all of these absolutely
and uh but even when i was a more
grown-up you know for me when when when
when you know it's anywhere between
sci-fi and fantasy whenever harry potter
came i would read the the entire series
i wouldn't even wait for a second you
know that that that is how it feels to
me
incredible
today
inspiration as a source for your
leadership for
you know your creativity your your
innovation you've been in this for 20
years you're still innovating you're
talking about how there's this big huge
opportunity that you're going to try to
conquer you know closing the loop 20
years later where do you get your
inspiration from
my kids
um
i'm seriously you know if if i needed to
understand something that i don't
understand from
you i mean i'm a freak of usability and
and to me if there's any window of of me
understanding better my users would be
either my users you know my our clients
our users that are actually using the
solution
but really when i'm i want to see i want
to get a glimpse to the future i would
go back and look at my kids and the way
they're using
any the way they consume any type of
technology today it's it's it's mind
muggling i'm telling you this is
absolutely
mind-boggling i can completely
understand that by the way
when you
transitioned from
from the director consumer to the brands
what was the hardest piece of it all
was it the you know internally with the
company was it you know shifting the
product this the new sales cycle that
you have to adapt to what was the most
what was the hardest part
i think all of the above look
first
it was the when we were talking about 20
years back the product was really way
you know it was sub
substandard sub ready it wasn't there
and
then hardware hey we had a
super computer back at the time that my
my iphone today is a hundred times
stronger than that so so it was all very
limited resources limited everything
so and the quality wasn't there as it is
today
so yeah number one was was taking the
consumers through hey what you see today
is going to improve
we know it's
almost almost as good as we would want
it to be it's not there yet they would i
would need to then
you know take them through my vision and
there were there were companies back
then back at the time that believed that
things will will
you know improve with time and were
willing to take the um
the
the journey from there from the
beginning even when things didn't look
you know amazing at the time i'm talking
about companies like adidas companies
like benetton they had an innovation
teams that were more than innovation you
know that
and there was nothing back at the time
so they were willing to to walk the
journey with us and did amazing things
with us uh um but that was the hardest
part to get
more than you know a handful of clients
it was i mean going from that point on
and you know that was the early time of
early adoption that was the hardest
stuff
and when you don't have enough clients
and you don't have enough revenues
you know
you're you're going there with minimum
resources and that was that was a fight
and the second thing is then of course
when when when this is going slow
taking the team behind you and and and
you know taking them through your
profession yeah
that that that's
that's hard as well but people i think
this is one of the things that we are
lucky in this company is that it's very
visual everything we do
you see on the screen and it has that
thing that people that are coming to
work in browser
not necessarily leaving so quickly
because because it is really inspiring
just to open the computer in the morning
and have that 3d you know rotating and
that makes your day already and from
from the very beginning of the day
right so that's a good thing for us that
was really you know i think that and and
us being able to me and my partners
being able to
to take the the the whole crew with us
through you know bad days and good days
but keeping the the
i think keeping the the
the
how do you call it the um
keeping the the
attention of everyone towards the
lighthouse
that that the one thing which was i mean
through the year the one thing that held
everyone
uh in the company
incredible avikai thank you very very
much this was fantastic this was
really really enjoyable and inspiring
and i can't wait to see
where browser is headed next and and i
and i'm energized by your energy and by
your vision and your optimism and your
you know your your innovative way of
thinking and i just love it so thank you
very very much and stay safe and stay
healthy oh thank you for uh letting me
uh talk and talk i felt that it was one
minute but now i guess the 20 minutes
have already gone
it always feel that way to me as well
thank you very very much
you